okay just to let you know this does have
some pretty ugly looking involved
algebra okay so my proofs can it go
through the board and I'm going to need
to wipe off the board as I go okay
so I'll try to fit it into another I'm
gonna make it I'm going to try and fit
it into two columns on the board by the
time I get down to the end of this
second column I'm going to wipe off the
first column I'm going to stop asking
you because I'm going to keep on asking
so just when I get to here make sure
you've got all of this down yeah alright
so probably should use this alright the
nth Fibonacci number now you're starting
to get a sense of why we have recursive
definitions for series because sometimes
if those nice to know in what individual
terms are and if you're a computer
scientist this is almost infinitely more
computationally efficient than working
out all the previous ones if you say one
from 102 the ninety number okay use the
recursive definition you've got to work
all out we've got to work out all 99 of
the ones before that and then you get to
the 101 right whereas this one even
though what we're you can go straight to
100 that's going to cool okay because
100 Fibonacci number is big it's
difficult to get to if you don't use it
so when we have you guide this um you
remember what your four steps are right
but immediately you run into a problem
as you get going so let's let's meet it
shall we we're going to test
for the first allowed without you okay
so this is one example of where the
these testing cases I'm not actually
trivial you have to be careful with your
numbers here okay so let's go ahead and
do it
testing for equals 1 we're saying
showing we go with the right hand side
and I'm going to simplify this up that's
1 plus root 5
okay happy when you expand your brackets
he just watch out for those double make
it is so I've got 1 plus root 5 minus 1
plus root 5 in all one survived okay
good I can manage my arithmetic so far
because the ones cancel I've got to 5 on
2 5 and everything is looking good so
far
okay that's equal to f1 the first
Fibonacci number so that's equal to the
left hand side so this thing is true for
the first allowable values by the way
maybe as you're starting to go forward
through this you start to sense why even
though there are irrational numbers in
the formula all the irrational numbers
will come out in the wash at least if
you're doing numbers right okay and it
has to do with these two being
conjugates of each other okay
anyway that's more of an aside now
usually I would go onto my assumption
and then my proof okay however just so
that it's more logical on your page and
on the board as well I want to do this
now even though you might not understand
why it'll become clear in step three for
this particular our proof I can't get
away with just doing the first allowable
value I've got to do the first two okay
so I'm not only we're going to test
fitting because one we're going to test
for and equal to also okay so again
right hand side
now just to uh just to be a little more
concise and take up this space I'm going
to skip some lines and working just
because I write something on the board
okay so I'm going to go straight to the
expansion on this dress
okay so like I said that's a little more
compact than I probably would like it if
it was one of your video answers I
especially think this line is important
okay to demonstrate you've done your
substitution properly but we're happy
it's true
okay now mmm I can just fit in the third
column let's let's see how far I can get
I can give my assumption now I can even
get down here actually to the assumption
since it's quiet simple I'm just going
to start if you guys know step solve all
the ends out for K's so assume
okay now comes the fun what are we
required to prove or to step three now
right okay that the k plus one Fibonacci
number is equal to
now where shall we start where shall we
start
I actually think this is one of the
unusual examples where you really could
go from either end because they're both
terrible okay I'm going to start from
the left hand side because I think it's
sort of when you're expanding out from
your assumptions I actually think it's
slightly easier ever so slightly okay so
I'm going to start on the left which is
this okay and now we can think about and
this is why I had to prove not just the
first loud baby the first two I can say
well what's that equal to what's the
definition of a Bonacci sequence right
the k plus one Fibonacci number is the
sum of the one for it and one before
that
okay so I guess I'd write that like so
okay because this is such a special case
maybe you can just say that but I'm
going to say by definition or if women
are Fibonacci sequence
all right now we get this next heart
okay because I don't know what these are
equal to apart from my assumption that's
where I have to substitute it straight
away okay now it's going to be a bit
terrible to begin with and it's going to
get more tone just because of these two
different fractions okay but keep your
eye on the prize okay if you have an
idea of where you're going um the
resultant value is gonna be much easier
okay
what's F of K it's this I'm sure so it
just goes to the Canadian now somebody
asked me before do I have to make two
assumptions because when I do this next
bit where am i or am i taking that from
and I think you really need to do a
second assumption because when I'm
working out the K minus one number I can
use the same assumption it's going to
follow exactly the same path so I'm
going to have the same fraction but K
minus ones
okay now again remember I said because
we're not just trying to sort of
simplify just blanket you know just get
everything down as oppose me we're
trying to get to a specific goal okay
you want to think about what's the
quickest path from A or B okay and I'm
looking at the moment at these
denominators okay
because I have to obviously do something
with them I've got to combine them into
one fraction but what's going to combine
them into any fraction I want to combine
them into one with that denominator okay
so what's the digit in this denominator
and the ones I've already got well this
one isn't big enough is it I need to
double it to get to there remember your
index laws okay that plus one just means
multiply my - okay so you probably have
this on a number line
but because I'm trying to scare space if
I were to make that a 2k plus 1 I'm
going to multiply it by two is that
again this goes together I multiply the
denominator so I multiply the numerator
also - now that's going to make this
denominator nice neat where I want it
when you look at this second denominator
I'm just different what do I have to do
to get it up to the denominator I want
multiply my two won't be enough Willa
okay because multiply that by two and I
just get to care I need to go again so I
can get to K plus 4 okay so I'm going to
multiply this by 4 2 squared so this
whole numerator also goes by 4
that's enough to actually get these on a
common denominator so I can put them in
one fraction
okay now you look at that Vichy chorus
alright well what can I do with this I'm
gonna have to keep on marching forward
with my numerator now that's actually
even though it looks terrible up here
the bottom is exactly where we want it
so now I don't need to do anything with
it okay so what can I do here to started
getting it towards that well by two
terms up here right so call that like a
minor rule and here I've got four okay
so I'm going to need to combine these
collapse them from four into two what's
the best way to do it well with my
colors you've got the one point plus
root 5 here right is is 1
you've also got the 1 plus root 5 here
ok so I take it that these two somehow
I'm going to fold into that 1 plus root
5 does that make sense
ok you can't really squeeze a 1 minus
root 5 so it turns into that it's it's
almost like collecting my terms
ok so these are my terms they're going
to click into that and in the same way
these two are going to collect into the
other one okay so let's try and collect
our like terms here where you get
upfront
oops
I miss them as I write this sorry I'm
getting I'm trying to save space right
um if I want to factorize these together
collapse them as I've seen before right
one be the common factor between these
two now the first thing you might say is
it's going to be one plus root 5 ok and
that is on the right track right but the
tricky human is because of these indices
right
how many got plus root fires are there
in there yeah so it's indeterminate
depends on what K is right if K were say
five ok let me fire them here and then
before here or if K was say 100 right
there'd be 100 here and 99 here so in
the comment the thing I'm going to
factor out is not just one of them but
well 99 39 right here and they'll be 99
and another one here ok so that's going
to be one color doesn't know that's
going to be in K minus 1 ok so I'm going
to try and make that factorization
obvious so here what's the difference
between this and that it's just one
extra one ok so I'm going to have 1 plus
root 5 times 1 plus root 5 to the K
minus 1 okay if you want make it a
little more obvious for yourself put a 1
there okay
what
Corphish I haven't got to here I'm just
doing all right yeah yeah so I'll get
another color all I've done is I'm
trying to make this I see this is why
you know you've got to keep an eye on
where you're going right I'm making this
less simple to make it easier to get
more simple in the particular way that I
want okay so that's why somebody the GP
okay alright there's the first term is
just broken apart and now I'm going to
put this one alongside it so my
factorization will be zero here's those
two terms I do exactly the same thing
with these two except it's just a - okay
so I'm going to have - two again I've
got one extra one at the front and then
one minus root 5 to the K minus 1
that'll be my factor and then forwards
okay so now I can factorize I can take
this 1 plus 1 5 to the K minus 1 stick
it out the front okay so let's be
careful here
how many lots of 1 + 3 5 to the K minus
1 how many of you line of them do I have
from this first term I've got 2 plus 2
root 5
lots of it and here I've got 4 there
factors now I'm going to do with these
two I'm since there's a minus there okay
I'm going to stick a minus here so I'm
going to have 1 minus root 5 to the K
minus 1 at the front okay and what are
we gonna have after it looks much as
soon as this doesn't look
okay now how's your brain go so far or
your your your pen ink okay
um at this point again you've got to be
watchful for rather than your instinct
is to simplify you've got to try and get
from here to there right
hmm all right now look carefully what's
the difference between what I've gone up
there say let's just because these are
so similar okay I'll think about one and
then the same hand should work for the
other what's the difference between this
and what I have down here same base
right but the index is different
I've got a K minus 1 here and a K plus 1
there what's the difference when the
indexes came over here and heckles
weren't there
it's a difference in the index - right
so to get from here up to here I'm gonna
have to multiply by that ^ - that that's
square okay now this is all I'm like how
can we make it a little more obvious
because apparently if we've done our
numbers right which we have okay that's
going to turn into 1 + 3 5 or square can
you see it yet
let me try make it one more step to make
more obvious he's here now this is not
the only way to do it but this is the
way I'm going to write it
and I'll do exactly the same thing
okay what did I do can you see it um I
mean not hardly any difference like
what's the point of that really I just
moved a one yeah I can you do you
numbers okay why did I put it in this
way because I think this makes it more
obvious this um these three terms here
right near in the format a squared plus
2 a B plus B squared right
so like completing the square yeah it's
just harder to recognize because you
have square roots in there
so you're like five out of square well
it is if you've got revived okay so
that's what makes my my factorization I
think a little more obvious
okay so now
the marking scheme if I saw this this
line and this line was skipped and went
straight to my own that around I think
that's okay I'm hardly doing this as a
teaching method so you see you're like
you know maybe you factorize to the next
Lane 6 plus 2 root fire you're like how
did that turn it to know what so I'm
just doing that so that is just clear
where are we going to go that's going to
become 1 plus root 5 K minus 1 and 1
plus root 5 squared now you can see I'm
almost there
I basically this is that's all the hard
work I think okay and then the same for
the conjugates
okay so now I can I've got same basis
now so I can combine the indices so that
part would be the party 1 k plus 1 and
this will be same
um let's see yeah I will not be writing
your tests because I teach you you stay
with sir unfortunately um yeah and I got
enough work for one human being a little
moving too so I think that'll be a bad
way to go
your plan is bad and you should feel bad
anyway um so there we go
take that to Bonacci it actually worked
out um and remember when you look at
this when you look back at this okay um
a lot of it looks very counterintuitive
like why don't you do that they were
simpler where leave me alone I'm simple
an African and then why this number
business just monkeying my talking on
this round okay so make sure on you're
working for this
you've got your highlighted in non color
somewhere off on the side why do we do
it this way um for this week and for you
know miss reason characterization and so